and different colors and uh there we are
the players have kicked off and we are
seeing the sea pawn move two squares
forward which is a tribute to us i'm
gonna take it it's called the english
opening yay
the english opening and how will we
react to this okay the black knight
comes out white gets ready to
fianchetto his bishop on the g2 square
very flexible and we might be
transposing into some kind of catalan
opening here we go black's set up this
kind of queen's gambit declined
structure black structure in the center
of the board rock solid
and what will level neurone do here if
white castles is king and if black does
the same
then big question do you go into the
catalan or do you play this kind of
really flexible system where you just
guard your pawn getting ready to fiance
to the other bishop now i like it but
it's very ambitious provocative by white
and there's a big question for wayu now
you know what plan is he going to be
adopting because there are several
possibilities you know he can step
forward with his deep warm one square
grab lots of space he can also
put another pawn on the fifth row but
his c pawn two squares forward or
alternatively he can just simply try to
develop the light squared bishop so i'm
kind of curious i've heard kind of that
the critical move is actually to expand
in the center grab the space
but is that in fashion
it's
not massively in fashion these days
normally when black sets up like this
black's happy to be very solid
um
he is quite an ambitious player so i
wouldn't be surprised to see black try
and gain some space to try and expand as
much as possible with those black pawns
but
yeah i mean the fact that he's even
thinking right now where he means he's
probably going to go towards a more
solid option
there we go just uh copying white
getting ready to put
black's light squared bishop on a nice
square meanwhile the white bishops in
this type of position do offer quite a
lot of long-term potential
yeah i mean it's just a nice quiet start
of the game really yeah
what do you think of this choice yeah i
used to play this when i first started
out playing chess this system is white
um i gave out quickly because i really
didn't enjoy it actually because it's
very slow positional safe
um and maneuvering
and i think we can see that that's um
i think quite a clever tactic from
aronian against someone like wei yi he's
got much more experience the age the
playing more games so i think he wants
to uh you know not go into something too
quickly not get something incredibly
sharp but more of a slow pace uh
maneuvering game where he can use that
experience to to to maybe get some
positional advantages so i think that's
that's his strategy from the opening
he's played and it makes a lot of sense
to me just to develop quietly and wait
for the action to occur uh later on in
the game
yeah mike just steps the pawn forward
there getting ready to kind of create a
nice square for the queen the white
queen normally sits on the square that
white porn used to
sit on on the e2 square and as simon
said lots of maneuvering ahead
he's settling in for the long grind here
ironian and wei yi
already thinking a little bit normally
he's quite fast in the opening
um yeah maybe it's because he's
uncomfortable or maybe he just didn't
expect this type of approach from levon
levon's secret to success so far in this
tournament has been being quite direct
playing very quickly on the clock which
we're seeing in this game as well but
also going for quite uh direct plans or
at least provoking the opponent
uh maybe quite rare openings this one is
more common but also
just a slower type of position so so
playing as fast as levon has been doing
over the last few days is that a sign of
him being very well prepared he's spent
some time all day prepare he knows what
he wants to play or is it as we always
talk about the you know his
this intuition just being on point yeah
i think it's a mix of both levon's been
playing a lot of what we call systems
where um you can just kind of play your
first 10 moves on autopilot you know
exactly what you're going to do
irrespective no matter what your
opponent does um so in a way you can
kind of do that with white here as well
you can just put the white queen on the
e2 square bring the white knight out
from the left side of the board
centralize the white rooks and then you
start thinking
so although this is a quieter type of
position i mean we're we've just seen
move eight from white i could definitely
envisage a situation where we're at move
15 and levon still has uh the same time
on the clock just because his next few
moves are quite straightforward it's up
to black to initiate uh to maybe fight
back in the center
so yeah decent choice of opening and
your other point there kya just
instinct levon's instincts have been
great he's calculated when he needs to
calculate he stops for two or three
minutes here and there but uh in general
instinctively just playing the moves as
quickly as he can it's a sign of
confidence as well isn't it i mean when
you're playing quickly yeah it is
generally a good sign that you're you're
in form um i think a lot of players like
this you know if you're playing a bit
stuttery you're slowing down it means
you're not confident and um well we see
where you playing one of the more
critical options there but i think this
just shows that aronia is in top form
and it's clear that he is on great form
during his tournament hence why uh he's
probably the favorite of this match
uh but i guess yuvanka we've sort of
seen this kind of set up fair a few
times yeah we have seen it hundreds of
times
again moving the queen to the square
maybe not the most popular but still you
know hundreds of games have been played
and uh where you continuing with a very
natural plan of development and lavon
aronian with that rook move it's getting
ready to instigate some action in the
center
the one thing i really like about wei yi
is that okay here it is it's how much
tea he drinks
and he does in such a civilized way as
well you know whenever there's a
decision to be made
cheers he drinks he drinks a sip
and china china and england the big tea
countries yeah and india as well india
as well yeah
wow and brazil as well i think it's
bigger isn't it maybe maybe it's just
the rest of the world that is just off
actually i think the most popular drink
in the world is tea is it yeah it is
more because i thought i was being super
healthy and be super kind to the world
but no no no there's a lot of uh more
popular than beer
but it can't be water surely
water yeah water's pretty pretty uh he
takes water so i guess uh water is out
of yeah
yeah yeah well i ever thought anyway
the tea plantations are
not uh great when it comes to the
environmental record and then i thought
okay now i need i need to make a special
effort there but okay
we see our players getting ready for
critical moment and
wei yi plays a slightly unusual move um
again only been played ten times and
it's actually to put the queen on this
particular square it's much more natural
to step up one square connecting the
rooks
but uh okay
here we have a change
yeah and this is quite a common idea in
a very similar position where instead of
white's queen coming out white's rook
coming across if white's queen side
knight then on the left side of the
board had developed instead then this is
actually black's most trendy move uh
putting the queen on this square the
idea is that the queen won't get hit
black's rook simply wants to slide
across to the square where the black
queen previously sat and also the fact
that the black queen and the light
squared bishop are lined up together
means that often the black light square
bishop's actually going to move
to the a6 square and yeah i mean this is
a very common idea maybe not in this
exact position but where ye is just
trying to use pattern recognition to
kind of realize okay he's been surprised
now there is maximum tension in the
center and black is decently prepared
for this i think
we will see a trade of one set of pawns
most likely right now
yeah it's uh it's a really interesting
choice by iranian have you noticed
something weird
about one of their cameras
anyone see what's going on in the
background
it seems to be i reckon where he's got
some ghosts in the house what the light
the light is flickering it gets going on
and off so uh have you seen it it's gone
a bit bright it goes a bit dark it could
be that mood lighting again i think so
unless i'm just seeing things which is
entirely possible
yeah that mood lighting is the theme
isn't it so it's like uh we'll keep an
eye on it see see if it's sort of uh
wouldn't that be so annoying though if
like his light is flickering and he's
trying to concentrate on the game yeah a
bit of strobe lighting can't be good
no so yeah but because we saw that of
course with duder as well i mean when he
had a good position it seemed to
his room seemed to light up for some
bizarre reason to say when he was losing
it was pitch black and pitch black as
well
maybe it was uh mother nature
you know kind of giving her verdict on
the position
it could be a friendly ghost yeah and
goddess of chess just signaling like i
do not approve of that movement
will not have any more light
[Laughter]
or more ambitious play more it would be
it would be quite cool actually to have
something so the players could know
how they're doing just an indicator
some sound effects maybe never maybe
just like a little bit red you know
unfortunately yeah because i've heard
that
by looking at the bar you can
you can sort of easily guess if that was
a good or a bad well because the bar
tells you but
the bar or any kind of indicator would
be a huge help to the players exactly
without the evaluation bar we would be
guessing a lot of the time when we see
the evaluation swing and
make a big significant jump that's when
we know that has been a blunder or
mistake that's when we know that one
side has a specific tactic
and then then you know what kind of move
to look for exactly the next move you
should play i mean often the players
they'll have a very good move and
they'll be looking at it but they don't
know whether it's a good one or not
they'll see oh it's really tempting but
i have to calculate 10 moves do i really
want to spend that time calculating and
they won't go for it if they see the
evaluation bar
go really in their favor they'll say
okay i don't even need to calculate i'm
going to play that it must be that more
it must be that it's basically like
someone's saying you've got a tactic
here it's the same thing you have a good
move
you know like literally someone's saying
here it is so it'd be a major advantage
and yeah i think it's been proposed that
that's a variant of chess that could be
could be played online even that you
know so they're allowed to look at the
evaluation bar like two times or
something could be an interesting way to
sort of spice up something i mean if
it's
but the way that i was thinking it
wouldn't be to kind of suddenly turn red
or sunny to turn blue i was thinking you
know have a bit more like in a quiet
position would be like a gradually
phasing to the red like and then
suddenly maybe it will turn blue maybe
turn green or maybe green and blue green
and red i like those colors better
and then you know would that person feel
panicked if they're like oh my goodness
me my position is actually getting worse
and worse and then suddenly it's green
again and then you're like oh what's
happening i just want to see well i
think the light's gone off again here
hasn't it is that right but anyway yeah
we should look at the moves but i mean
i'm more interested in the light in
terms of sound
you're like in uh
what's the english or electric uh
electrician yeah electricity electricity
you've been following a lot of the
lighting for this yeah probably
more than the moves it's a bit worrying
isn't it maybe i'm just born to be an
electrician oh maybe you are
sorry
there's worse things to be yeah very
good job yeah meanwhile only one move
and that is black keeping the tension
moving the rook across
yeah these four pawns in the center it's
as if neither side really wants to touch
them yet neither side wants to give way
and make that exchange make that trade
i'm expecting either level neroni and
now to catch one of the pawns in the
center or for white's knight
that's kind of idle night to come out
into the game
it's so hard i mean if you do capture a
pawn which one do you capture maybe we
can jump in and show why this is a bit
of a dilemma for both players uh okay we
don't have to show these uh these pawn
exchanges they will happen eventually
first level just gets ready by bringing
his remaining night out the pawns are
kind of interesting they're like forming
a cross like don't enter this position
i have an expression for this uh
whenever i prepare a position like this
in my chest notes i write maximum
tension it's a standoff and
you know because there's so many
captures as david highlighted and uh of
course
i feel that levon aronian has actually
got this better chances here because
the black queen feels slightly
uncomfortable
i agree i mean it's just the queen isn't
it really i mean like
with david showing that the rook can
come there yeah i mean that
must be a bit of advantage david do you
think for white definitely uh black
would love to do something now something
concrete i think the big question is
whether you can capture one of these
pawns either this pawn or the pawn next
to it if you take this guy the big
question for white is which way are you
going to recapture do you play with
pawns and hope for example that you get
this type of situation we call these
hanging pawns because they're kind of
hanging in the center in midair
they have to be supported by pieces they
can't support each other and the problem
is it's not immediately easy to push
this one forward that square would be
covered and likewise you don't really
want to push this one forward because
you lose control over squares so they
kind of hang in the center of the board
forever they do kind of restrict the
black pieces but your white pieces are
tied down defending them for a long time
but uh if we go back if black does
capture a pawn the question for white is
do you take with pieces do you play with
pieces instead of pawns in the center of
the board
and here for example if we see another
exchange
most likely white would start playing
with pieces in the middle and this type
of situation does white have an
advantage it's completely symmetrical
now the pawn structure
the reason i would slightly prefer white
it's not much but uh again it's because
as you guys say black's queen is sat on
a vulnerable square the big question for
me here is whether black can just trade
off a bunch of pieces maybe give a check
with the queen everything disappearing
for example we could even see the queens
come off in a situation like this and
maybe white has a small advantage
because these two pieces are pretty
decent there's also a hole in black's
position this is quite a common theme
and the knight jumping in but
it's very reduced material right now and
this one could fizzle out to a draw if
black is accurate
but it's not way east style if we
retreat the whole way back to the
current position it's not necessarily
where you start to trade a set of pawns
try and trade off all the pieces like we
saw in that last variation
the question is for black what else
spending a lot of time isn't it i mean
this this is why i think another reason
aronian's opening choice is very clever
i mean it shouldn't really lead to a
tangible advantage but uh i think that
way he is uncomfortable just because the
time he spent he spent half of his time
already
i think he prefers more clear-cut
positions where there's clear-cut sort
of tactical things to do
so playing this kind of very cagey setup
where there's multiple choices
i think his experience you know is going
to be a little bit lacking um and well
we see there that uh ironian does take
with a pawn
in the center which which maybe is
more demanding on black's position
definitely
and whilst the players are
taking a pause and thinking about what
to do next
well of course it's the final it's going
to be maximum drama so much excitement
and we love it when you at home get
involved in all the action so we would
definitely love to see your selfies
remember to take them in landscape mode
and the black queen steps forward but to
kick us all off uh john brazel sends us
a selfie he says hey chess fam another
beautiful day to enjoy the outdoors and
the road to miami
and uh abhishek also sends us a very
cool picture he says that when my
opponent plays a stupid move
and also this deer at long leads didn't
like what i offered sorry dear oh dear
okay i went to long league
a while back about six months ago yeah
because they got a safari there and it
was the worst trip ever um because you
have to you go around in your car
it takes about an hour and a half and as
soon as i got in i realized i needed to
go to the toilet oh no and it was like
and you're in the lion in cage show and
you have to and there's cars in front of
you so you can't like go around them and
it's literally an hour and a half of
like oh my god
can i get out here no there's a lion oh
no what about here behind the bush tiger
it's like oh no rhino it was yeah very
painful trip did you go in the monkey
enclosure
uh what have we or no no i mean
did you drive in in it because i've
heard that's the most fun because the
lions i'll be honest with you there
might be ferocious beasts but they're
lazy they do nothing but just
hang around in the sun meanwhile if you
go drive in the monkey park they're
on you on top of your car playing with
the wind
they jump all over it they pull off the
things yeah it's not actually that much
fun you know watch it on tv safer
or have a toilet on board
that's my tip for longleats
but i i guess you you still prefer
whitehead david do you slightly or um
yeah slightly i always find it really
difficult to play white's position i've
had something very similar to this
if not identical and
the tension in the center is really
unpleasant for white
if you're kind of impatient like i am
occasionally here white's pieces look
great they look like they protect each
other they're controlling some central
squares at least pointed towards the
center the question is what next you
can't really push your central pawns
forward with white you don't want to
trade any more pawns you just need to
maneuver pieces
and i guess it's similar for black but
black can just kind of relax and sit
back and say okay the pressure's on you
you have more pawns in the center as
white you have more responsibility
um yeah i mean if we just jump into the
position once more i just i'm struggling
to find a productive move with white
uh this is the tension we never ever
want to trade this pawn now as white
okay levon moves his bishop we never
want to trade this because suddenly
white has two isolated pawns on the
queen side and long term that will come
back to bite him and likewise we can't
push forward in the center this square
is simply covered too many times but
levon wants to push forward in the
center hence his last move moving the
bishop to this diagonal
and now maybe a threat if black's pawn
pushes forward the white pawn can step
forward in the center and now okay
bishop takes rook is on offer i'm not
100 sure this is actually what white
wants to do because suddenly white has
won the exchange a rook for bishop but
white's light squares are extremely weak
around his king side and i could imagine
a situation where this bishop comes open
onto the diagonal and wreaks havoc so i
i don't really understand
lev's last move i mean it's it's maybe a
clever move but
i i it's a move i never would play in my
life so i'm very intrigued
you know to see if well will he now try
to win the exchange that i mean
incredibly risky to get rid of your uh
bishop your fianceto bishop around your
king right i don't think he can try this
anymore unfortunately
has just pinned
this pawn so uh if the white pawn steps
forward black can even play for example
knight takes pawn this knight is
poisoned because of the pin white's
queen would drop to the black bishop and
levon yeah hence has to wait
uh he just moves his knight across
putting some pressure maybe on this this
square levon's just really really
begging wei yi to capture in the center
so that finally at least okay he has
these hanging paw hanging pawns but at
least suddenly there's no more tension
at least he can kind of play around
these pawns in the current situation uh
it's all about the tension here and it's
a bit uncomfortable
for both sides
i must admit i also a bit baffled by
level naronian's plans and
i i
it kind of goes against my understanding
of the position as well
um i've always just thought you just sit
like weights white weights and okay here
but actually uh way ye has stepped back
with the queen
and uh this is a great move because the
queen gets oh
hang on a second is there a reason why
it's not i thought i was loving this
move people why would it be a great
movie it's on a bad squat no yeah the
reason i don't i like it is because the
queen gets out of the island of the rook
and for me i always feel very
uncomfortable okay so at least a safe
square yeah and this is the big question
does white have a strong move now
i'm looking is it
this i mean this one does this work now
i guess black's knight can still capture
in the center utilizing the fact that
this is a pin so white's porn cannot
take this knight
uh for example pawn takes knight the
white queen would just drop off
um what else if white can't push this
pawn
then what else can you try lev on a
ronin i was wondering about this oh he's
going he's he's getting ready to uh
well i say sacrifice but it might not
even be a sacrifice capture
um that pawn right which is but that's a
big decision as well out of the blue
it's out of nowhere it's this ambitious
play by levon aronian
wow nice yeah and the whole idea simon
says this for example normally when an
opponent's knight lands in your half the
board you want to kick it back if black
does try to kick this knight out of his
half then knight takes pawn
and you mention it's not a sacrifice
simon i mean firstly it's a check
at the very minimum you can just capture
the black rook maybe you don't even do
this maybe you just step forward with
the pawn yeah try to open up this
bishop's line towards the black king but
even if you were to capture this rook
for example you can now have two central
pawns
and a rook for black's two minor pieces
so a small material advantage for white
yeah yeah big threat it's
i think again that this is showing it
what good form arron is on
because he's spotting these moves which
are not obvious uh immediately you know
just really really quickly and i i that
just indicates he's really on the top of
his game because a move like that okay
you're kind of bit committed
it's a little bit strange to put the
night there unless you're going to
sacrifice it and uh well it's going to
be very interesting now because um
how do you stop that move that david
pointed out the knight coming in and
grabbing that pawn and um starting a big
attack as well that would also weigh
down to four minutes so he's nearly six
minutes down on the clock compared to
iranian
i don't see a good way to stop this
maybe we can check the stockfish
suggestions because how narrow is
black's path to survival the evaluation
bar says white is only slightly better
but if you step wrong you might be
significantly worse and okay he doesn't
play any of the top three moves there
black's best moves were for example
shuffling the rook across
maybe going to this square with the rook
to guard this pawn that would have been
maybe more logical but now
he's moved this port rook anyway this is
just begging to be like
some sacrifice here i mean what do you
capture on e6 with i mean the night i
think knight takes is definitely the
move level play because uh you can win
material by capturing that pawn with the
bishop i feel
um
but
after a quite a four sequence you're
going to come out basically uh a porn up
you've given up uh you've given up your
your very strong minor pieces uh at the
end of this so i think you i think he
will grab it with a knight and make it a
pure sacrifice and do a similar thing to
what you said david uh start pushing
those pawns in the middle i don't know
which one d5 e4 coming next and look at
those pawns in the center look at those
bishops this looks uh i'd love to be
white at this position this is like a
lovely lovely structure to have i have
to say um i love this position as well
but uh i think i'll be tempted to grab
material i'll try and try to get the
same
what take with the take with the bishop
on e6 yeah and try to get the same kind
of pawns i i know i know i couldn't do
it i just couldn't do it
i'd much rather be points down the
points up obviously yeah it's probably
the wrong thing but i i maybe it maybe
it's a good move maybe it's a matter of
taste there what i can't actually see
what stockfish says my bad vision the
computer's with you simon the computer
wants to just give up a knight for two
pawns um just to show that final
position one more time after a few
captures the black king moves and white
steps forward uh oh he hasn't done any
of those moves he's played the second
top stockfish moves okay um i was gonna
say uh it's a matter of taste because in
this position ivanka preferred to take
with a bishop and that was the third top
computer move so a matter of taste there
levon doesn't want to commit instead he
just captures a pawn opening up this
central line computer still likes this
for white but uh much less than it did
the sacrifice it's kind of a pity to
give up your center which was which was
so nice
in the last position but the sacrifice
is still there uh in the middle of the
board and you have opened up your your
other bishop so if you look at white's
bishops they are fantastic
criss-crossing
across the board like that lovely little
pattern there x marks the spot of doom
and it might be that square around there
where it was actually going to happen as
well
yeah definitely x meets yeah this is
when chess becomes uh mathematics right
yeah a little bit yeah just i think it
is that vision in chess you know you
have to see the potential the pieces and
uh yeah this is this is maybe a simple
way to demonstrate that right um really
nice i've never even thought of that
pattern before but it just happens to be
coincidence that maybe the danger would
happen on one of these squares where the
bishop's eye lines are pointed at
meanwhile where he did try to swap a set
of rooks and levon is thinking which way
is he going to recapture its check right
now so he will take either with his rook
or with his queen that would be a cool
thing to investigate a little bit in
many games where you have two bishops
crossing each other how often will the
place they cross each other be
the crucial spot yeah we could have
found something there yeah yeah let's
copyright it get the chat yeah you got
it how did you get just about to say
that
my next my chest ball course 150.
x marks the spot yes yes
bring it on so
yeah it's going to be named after you
then simon
found something new in chess
named simon x oh my god yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah i mean we were saying
like there's no grandmaster just with a
name of one letter so maybe uh yeah
maybe maybe in the future but do you
remember our crypto cup challenge
everyone go find a friend or film
yourself naming as many grandmasters as
you can in only 30 seconds and post your
video of yourself or challenging your
friends with a surprise on twitter using
the hashtag chess champs and crypto cup
challenge
we want to see them we want to show them
you guys attempting our challenge simon
did 12 names but he
had to do full names you only have to do
last names that's enough so i kind of
got double points there you say 12 but
as i said both names surely that's 24.
yeah actually got 13 if we can count 26
here
yeah so i reckon i'm more 25 mark really
yeah just just you know it's good you're
not bitter about it
not at all
we're not competitive in the studio at
all
just make that clear
and obviously
should be one of your players that's a
short name to say wait
yeah way you ding thank you david i know
dave is going to destroy it i could just
i can just see it i can see him just
all the short names yeah we'll find out
tomorrow i'll probably freeze under the
lights yeah remember it's an ongoing
challenge yeah so uh you can definitely
challenge all your friends we would love
to share it during the breaks and also i
can't wait to see how everyone does when
you do it properly yeah which is like
under pressure yeah under that's maybe
the coolest if you surprise a friend
with it yeah because if you film
yourself which is completely allowed
but then you can do a little bit of
preparation but i mean we would like to
see a world record in this challenge as
well oh so prepare all the short names
well 18 is the tops right
although you should be well yeah easy
to break i think so okay especially if
you've got a list there some people
could cheat couldn't they they've got
yeah
i like to see how magnus gets on with
that as well that'd be interesting to
see if he uh if he can get a lot of
names so
um but yeah and we have do we have a
couple more moves so
now yeah so i was wondering here david i
mean like i don't think black will take
that pawn back but if he does is there a
big like blow you know if black just
goes pawn takes pawn for example does
white have something nasty oh he has
taken it back so this is the kind of
position where you're now certainly
looking for a sacrifice i mean or to
bring another piece in because look at
white's pieces right the bishops the
knight uh the rook the queen might have
potential they look very
scary to me um but is is there something
valuation bars really shot up again so i
think your instincts are correct simon
so um instincts say there's something
for white because all these pieces are
kind of pointing towards the black king
you have the open file um you have
everything basically so what is the
knockout can you just threaten like
checkmate i mean get the queen yeah this
move nice um we were talking about the
crisscross i was just looking at the
night so um
if we can get rid of the night our queen
dives in
and every piece is like attacking
black's king all of a sudden
i mean uh big threat now yeah big threat
for example if black does nothing then
bishop takes knight as you say removing
the defender and suddenly white's queen
jumps in
teaming up with the knight and the black
king is doomed
checkmate is coming in a few moves
so yeah huge threat how do we guard
against it this is the current weakness
this pawn is defended by black's knight
but not for long
where he needs to find a way to keep it
defended you could do this in two ways
both of them are really ugly i've got to
say one you could step this pawn forward
just to block this bishop out but this
looks superficial while wave really
plays with fire i was going to say next
you could push this pawn forward but
then you weaken this diagonal
instead while we've seen some real
tactics the pawn steps forward hitting
the white knight remember levon's idea
was to remove the black knight the
defender and way he says okay you've
removed my knight i know you're
threatening to come in but i can get rid
of your piece the supporting piece so
white queen cannot dive in anymore
clever defense maybe yeah yeah i think
so yeah
an important kind of motif of the
counterattack and now we see a trade of
bishops
but there is a problem with black's
position and that is
the double g pawn i mean i'm just
looking at that g5 pawn
it's a little bit vulnerable i have to
say
this one
and when you combine that with the rook
standing on an unchallenged open line
you feel that maybe black can be
stretched in two directions yeah i think
the question for white is whether you
can get this knight into the attack
whether you can get your queen in the
attack now and uh this queen move it
does again hint
one bishop's gone so there's no more
crisscross but it does hint at some
sacrifices on the square for example
again if black waits
not sure how but uh for example that
might be a nice sacrifice hitting the
king and uh breaking through
so okay
where you has to be on red alert in the
current position
this is potentially a threat and the
secondary threat like ivanka said is
going for this pawn so maybe just uh
whoops
uh maybe just stepping the queen forward
hitting this guy
and also potentially if you step your
queen forward some pins along this
diagonal
i think this might be the big threat
this queen move actually it's very
unpleasant for black still i mean uh i
think where you did an okay job there of
surviving the first storm but the the
pressure is still still on and
left playing fantastically at the moment
finding all these ways just to put
pressure on wei yi and uh you're right
that that that queen move looks looks
really unpleasant uh but also the
sacrifice both moves and what about time
situation okay two minutes for waiting
two minutes now so it's just under four
minutes for levon and yeah i mean this
bishop's offside i wanted to recruit it
just to line up hit the queen queen
stepping forward
it's just disaster for black this pawn
is dropping and this pin as well really
really awkward to deal with the other
pawn as well yeah exactly
misery comes in threes yeah yeah and uh
okay instead of that
black reacted by just shuffling the
queen across defending this square so
there's no sacrifices but
evaluation bar hates that move
can white just still go for a pawn i
guess if you step forward with the queen
now going for this guy then at least you
lose touch with this c4 pawn
so uh not a hundred percent easy for
level or onion i'd love to get this
knight into the game well you could
throw another piece into the game here
as well i mean like and create a threat
yeah
oh he does it
you're right simon big threat so for
example again if not sure how black does
nothing if black moves the knight for
example then rook takes pawn
suddenly and a double attack
hitting the queen but this is also check
you win yeah it's a lovely lovely place
for the rook it seems anyway right right
in the position so so black with his
back against the wall at the moment this
piece also a bit loose i mean yeah this
looks devastating i mean there has to be
a defense i mean is it just simply to
challenge that rook step it forward
step blacks rock forward
maybe
hmm
that could be an antidote
an answer to this rook move suddenly
we don't really want to trade uh rooks
but here for example if white's queen
avoids the trade a queen trade is
possible potentially but if we move then
we've got to be a bit careful that black
doesn't counter attack on this diagonal
and ivanka is right this was black's
reply offering a rook trade now
okay to take that well not to take that
you could retreat with white but you
lose a bit of momentum yeah and you just
come from there haven't you so this is a
good good defensive move definitely
i think where you say he's defending
well i mean he could have easily gone
wrong by this stage already and
he's uh he's holding on well at the
moment in a tricky position really
tricky i mean one one question is what
happens if white steps back with the
queen saying okay i'm wanting to come up
and check you and win the black queen so
of rook trade if it happens at least now
with white you're hitting this pawn
you're more importantly you're hitting
this black knight
maybe the black knight just moves
is this enough for white lavon's got to
ask himself this question right now
trade rooks or no trade what is that
what is the main factor in levon's
position that makes you say he is much
better in this game it is the main
factor it's just comparing all the
pieces so it's level pieces almost
symmetrical pawn structure but white's
rook at least temporarily is more active
than the black rook it's on an open line
uh here white's queen is much better
than the black queen it's nicely
centralized white's knight is slightly
better than the black knight because
it's got some pressure on this pawn
it's not clear whose bishop is better
maybe white's temporarily because again
some pressure on this square
the target is the black queen so it's
just all of these small things adding up
white's pieces are more active than the
black counterparts that's why um he's
done doing a great defensive job he sees
he senses that levon's pieces are more
active especially the rooks here clear
imbalance white pieces far better so in
chess if you
if you know your opponent has a strong
piece try and trade it off
so good strategy and levon has allowed
that he did drop his queen back
we do see the
trade of rooks and black's knight under
fire moves out the way
difficult question now do we take the
knight
if we take the knight black has these
kind of two sets of double pawns here oh
that's strange like a weird i don't know
box of double pawns yeah but uh the
problem for white maybe is that firstly
this pawn is attacked but secondly the
light squares are so weak near his king
gonna be a bit careful here if he takes
that knight off the board
the problem is after this night jump as
well you would love to win a pawn with
white you'd love to play queen takes
porn for example but here at the very
end black can regain a pawn and the
position should just be a draw now
okay maybe where he is defending maybe
he needs to keep rooks on the board
level on ironian because in the current
position if we go back to it the queen
is attacked and
if she has to retreat that's not good
news
the attack is fizzling out with every
exchange that's made everyone needs to
keep all these pieces on the board
really advantageous okay not easy to
achieve and uh well he's in a difficult
choice of how to maintain the momentum
and you can see his clock is ticking
down to just over a minute he's lower on
the clock for the first time in the game
definitely and okay the heat is on yeah
this is where we say ding ding ding
time trouble
i need another word than ding ding ding
what's a good word
no
we can use ding yeah yeah sure he'd be
honored to have his name linked to such
an important moment in the game exactly
yeah yeah
and uh well now the clock is down to 45
seconds
and such a tough decision to make you
mean he's done such a good job of
defending hasn't he i mean very
impressive because it's a really tricky
position i mean
i don't know i mean david what what do
you think about okay so this this is
again again very quick move there uh
straight away um
is there any way that white can keep
this game going white has to be very
careful if you leave the queens on the
board the white king could be weak on
the light squares but we'll wait one
second i mean there is a capture that
you can okay he's played it and the
whole idea that i'm thinking is after
bishop takes pawn
yeah there's a check there's a check
yeah did he just miss this mm-hmm you
just blunder a point i think he did
maybe he just missed this he literally
like took a a step well not a step but
he kind of moved backwards and kind of
shake and now i see a shake in his head
he got a bit excited there and uh found
a tactical shot that didn't quite work
this often happens doesn't it you defend
so well in a game but then when you
relax
uh it all goes wrong and hang on a
minute this just looks phenomenal for
white look at that pawn yeah in the
middle of the board it's just a it's
just a free strong pawn and black
black's king can't get near that pawn
because all the squares are controlled
and
i think the white king's just gonna come
and win yeah surely you guys are
completely right white's king once it
breaks open it's slightly hard for the
white king to approach the center of the
board but if the white king can start
approaching kind of start traveling
towards the left flank then it's just
game over i think wei yi might just give
this one up oh this is a clever move
maybe day i mean
only way to try and stop the king coming
in right the king is locked in i mean
how is the white king going to break out
this is what you need to do right the
only question remaining for levon
aronian get that white king out yeah
this last move was essential if black
was one move too slow and white had been
able to push the f pawn out the way
getting the white king over
easy win for white can the one just push
that pawn now yeah the problem is it all
could just get captured
uh if you push it one square it gets
taken this white f pawn if you push it
two squares on passant the black pawn
takes it
anyway so
how the ampersand that's why we
beginners we forget the amp facade yeah
the way f1 would love to move two
squares forward and then game over not
just beginners i mean like i just i know
england number one uh mickey adams
forgot it a couple of times when he was
playing he's lost he's lost two games
from forgetting about the on pass on wow
yeah
yeah i wasn't aware of that actually
yeah i think i think one against neil
mcdonald uh where he forgot he lost to
neil mcdonald quite a long time ago and
then i can't remember who the other one
was but i remember him or someone turned
me so yeah it's brutal yeah yeah pretty
so yeah and uh meanwhile we talked about
the white king being trapped the black
king is also stuck on the back rank
the problem for white is he would love
to use the knight white tonight would
love to hop around attacks and pawns or
maybe kick away black's bishop from the
cage it's created on the white king but
white's night as soon as it moves the
black king can come towards your far
advanced pawn
okay a bit of triangulation we call from
uh levon aronian white's king has just
done a little triangle but still not
breaking out
the valuation bar says plus one for
white but what is the winning plan yeah
i don't see it oh and he plays your move
kaia yeah yeah yeah
yeah forgotten about them
the only way to try it does it i think
as well okay so he's still trying
levonorony and you're trying but oh it's
nice he was one pawn up but he gave that
pawn back uh via on passant in order to
try and get the white king out but now
the white king has to sit as a defender
the pawn in front of it it's a past porn
black people pawns yeah yeah actually
you're right
whoa wait one second here
i am i just checked the evaluation
because i was thinking something is a
bit fishy black only has one way to draw
this position he has to stop the white
knight getting active he has to stop it
getting to the b3 square so only the
move bishop d1 will draw oh wow okay and
how long has he got he's got
he's got he's got two minutes so he can
get to the essence of the position he
plays it oh wow he plays this key move
if uh if he'd moved the black king the
white knight would have stepped back to
this square and stepped into the center
putting pressure on the bishop the pawn
and this pawn and for example here i
think white would be winning you capture
this pawn and harry would run through to
become a queen so yeah he spotted it
very well played
really narrow path to survival in this
position bringing the bishop to cover
this square
now white's knight can't really get
active if you drop back to this square
i guess the black king is just going to
come and take your pawn
still a bit tricky here white's knight
could jump in for example with the track
it's really odd this pawn structure it's
like
freddy is one of his triplets
uh okay level iranian instead of
allowing the black king out the black
king's still stuck on the edge of the
board uh covered by this knight
he pushes a pawn level on iranian
but now what happens if there's a
capture is he going to ignore this pawn
no more triple pawns on the f file if
you take this pawn with the white knight
suddenly the black king again five
seconds getting active
he doesn't take this pawn so levon's
give just giving up all of his pawns uh
and he's just trying to say okay if you
push your pawn forward now yes you have
three really scary pawns but the white
knight is gonna get into the position
and win this guy and suddenly again he's
gonna try and use all of these black
pawns as a distraction in order to get
his knight active
it's really risky though i was going to
ask that i mean is he taking too much
risk
i mean
yeah what's willie's best move here oh
he gives up a pawn he's about to promote
so this pawn is captured but now there
this is really clever from way ye at
least in defensive terms because now he
got rid of this white h pawn and uh
black is still temporarily a pawn up
shaking his head meanwhile black has
this extra pawn can you keep it maybe by
pushing your pawn forward yeah i was
thinking that or treating the bishop
he has one and a half minutes to figure
out how to capture sorry how to maintain
that pawn
and
i actually preferring black's position
here the problem is how's black ever
going to win black's king is so bad
livon already again shaking his head
yeah i think in practical terms white
should still be okay even if the
evaluation bar says black's
uh to be preferred here
one thing white should not do i'm
guessing is to capture black's pawn in
the center of the board because then
after a trade of bishops and knights
i think it's going to be very risky for
white even that is unclear maybe that's
just a draw
draw 16 seconds just left on iranian
take this black central pawn you have to
calculate a king and poor man game there
and it's so hard to do with 10 seconds
on the clock he doesn't make that
commitment he moves his king
makes sense as well yeah max king's in a
cage
can uh
black get a little bit fresh and give a
check to the white king
try to entice the king to go into lands
that he should not go
and uh no way he just simply waits with
the king this is also a good strategy
just leave the position open and full of
choices and now
six seconds
he needs to do three seconds two seconds
yeah make a move
and it retreats the king he made that
with two seconds on his clock yeah he
needs to just repeat the position
somehow just sit wait do nothing and
okay second time we've seen this
position
yeah neither king can get active really
i mean i i've seen where you
you know in in the other games not i've
i reckon he's going to play on with
black here uh do well i say that is it
going to be a draw already i mean if
there's any way you can play on but
probably there's not any way you can
play on
three seconds three two
one take the draw okay
he made that with one second to spare i
mean he's playing with fire here right i
mean he really is and way he can keep
the game going maybe by moving the king
the other way and trying to bring it
around that way i mean it should of
course be a draw but
i i think lev should be happy with a
draw at
this point in the game definitely and he
is he's playing on i this is what he
does right he plays on did you see it
was really sneaky
he always stays at the board he barely
ever looks away for one second he just
kind of looked to the right of his
screen he looked at the clocks
and then he decided to play for a win so
uh
for the first time in the game he's the
one
pressing and trying to play for the
advantage oh
yeah he's so calm where he even when he
blunted earlier or maybe not blundered
but when he was on the defensive um
yeah he was just ice-cold barely
flickered
and suddenly really focused wayyy
okay do you touch one of the black pawns
if you touch the black pawns you do
leave a square or two for the white
knight to jump into i thought black
might might be able to try bring his
king
to where the pawn on the light square is
uh possibly but you're never going to
move that king too far forwards because
white's pawn is is is too strong but i
mean of course it should be a draw but
can can you you know
can you try to use those two pawns to go
up and create some some problems black
wants to win you have to push the black
f4g pawns from one of them i mean a
winning plan would be able to move
uh freddie two squares fours
with gary defending it but maybe we
don't have a lot of time to show that
but yeah as you say he's gotta he's
gotta use those pawns right david it's
about pushing these pawns if you want to
win and trying to sneak the black king
around he's done it he's going for it
with 20 seconds left i know and the
players with seconds to spare they are
facing critical choices
and lavon pushes forward with his a pawn
can both players win or is it the one
fighting for a draw where are you trying
to win it i think they can both win but
it it it certainly yeah i mean
especially if we overpresses now
which he could do it's just uh but i
think way he has the better chances that
they're kind of like a narrow path easy
to make mistakes as well especially for
white okay i like what levons are doing
he's getting his pawn ready for any
potential race later on just in case he
can win the black a pawn but for wei yi
the one difficult thing for him is
keeping in touch with this pawn uh on
the last go and in the near future okay
still now he's able to stop this pawn
for example if it steps forward he can
drop his king back suddenly the white
knight is tied down this pawn is going
nowhere but he has to be really careful
where he puts the black king and it's
all about these pawns stepping forward
that one just retreats with his king and
surely wiggy now he's going to start
initiating pushing these pawns it's not
easy to push this one that's the problem
if you push too far
then you just get captured so
wow okay he retreats the bishop instead
and he's going to try and go around with
this piece still should be a draw
because i think white's pawn is too
strong but let's see if where you can
make progress both players under 20
seconds
and
we're yi repeating the position
probably just two times trying to get
more time on the clock so he can think
about complications and uh he goes for
it he's pushing the g pawn
the question is what next
i mean the only thing i can see if he
pushes the f pawn and then the g pawn
off for a capture but i mean kenny can
you try that david or is that is that
not working ever yeah um
it's very it's risky does come with a
bit of risk that's the problem for black
yeah um also any time we go down to a
king and porn game uh pink king and pawn
end game um if the bishops and knights
disappear and i'm assuming all of the uh
pawns on the right half disappear white
strong pawn disappears if we're just
left with the a pawns now i really like
what level neronian has done white's
pawn is so far up the board there it
will take black and age to capture it
meanwhile white's king can run towards
the corner so any king and pawn end
games now
where it's just the acorns left it's
gonna be a draw
um yeah
i think unfortunately for wei yi pushing
any of those pawns is
too risky right now and if you can't
push the pawn then
the only i mean where can that bishop go
the bishop can't actually go anywhere uh
that's that's of any use at all
um so this this is definitely looking
like a draw as we've seen before way he
doesn't like taking drawers doesn't he
he likes 100 moves can he get there i
don't know how many moves there's one
idea that i potentially see isn't that
is actually trying to get the bishop to
the c6 square so the bishop
perhaps
will keep an eye on the pawn
and
maybe this allows in some situations
it's going to be a tall ask i admit that
the black king can get active yeah i had
no idea how the bishop could get there
that's the problem i don't think it has
a root does it uh
if the white king takes a step back then
it can get to the d5 square and then get
to the c6 square and
basically we're
just
taking it move by move oh wow trying to
force the issue
it certainly
provoked a response from levon aronian
and
this looks good enough actually to
secure the draw
this is it
this looks like it will secure the
drawer after knight takes pawn
black's king has to go towards the white
pawn
and
here we go we're headed towards an end
game where
computer might say that it's plus one
for white but white's remaining pawn is
just gonna drop off unfortunately you
can't really go and save that white pawn
okay he's trying but
we will see a situation where the white
knight and the black pawn on this side
of the board just balance each other out
and yeah this one is
no chance of progress for white
it's quite quite a funny draw actually i
mean because white white is a piece up
right um
it's not uh you know
but the white knight can the point is
the white knight can never move because
black queens gets an extra queen and if
the white king
tries to go towards that pawn then white
will lose his last pawn and then it's
at least a draw for black so it's uh
yeah yeah it's like a matte equation and
you can just kind of rule out that white
knight and that black pawn just
they're just not part of the equation
anymore
and here we go black's king will likely
step back
and no way forward for white if you go
again towards that black a pawn to
attack it black's king slides the whole
way back
to defend
it's basically king and one versus king
and one the white knights and black pawn
just cancel each other
completely i wonder if it's instead of
draw if black loses his a pawn
no no no no no here's the answer but
like yeah
okay white's knight can actually lose a
move as we say just retreating forcing
black's king back every time but
here we go i think levon iranian is
ready to reconcile himself to a draw
it's impressive how calm way he was when
he gave up his bishop to secure this
draw
tough game right good fighting game to
get started there i mean high quality
very good yeah very good game so
the one aronian just debating
is it is it about uh repeating the
position right now yeah or offering a
draw repeating you can basically do both
um nothing can go wrong at all for white
here
so okay he just pushes his pawn forward
slightly odd another 50 more there's
another 50
okay he's setting a small trap if
black's king comes into the center of
the board the white knight might be able
to check it fork it and win the black
pawn so if you remove the g pawn now
would it still be a draw
well that's a good question
g pawn didn't exist and you just plucked
the black king in the corner
i think it would be a drop i think it's
a draw actually if you take the g pawn
off but instead we see a repetition of
the position and the first draw of the
final
they are still tied one game into the
final the first match levon aronian with
the white pieces he was fighting for a
win in this one but eventually after 79
moves and 53 minutes